[Music]
an unusual chain of events news thank
you submitted by man on the moon we've
never been to the moon
oh you're one of those no I am one of
those you think they're people that so
[ __ ] mad because I said like I don't
give a [ __ ] if you went to the moon but
like oh your arrogance progress also be
like I don't think the moon exists
that's is like conspiracy that's tight
to see how many people buy into it the
moves are sad a lot yeah well it is it
is a satellite because anything that
orbits our it's a satellite but it's
also a man they say it's an alien
satellite keeping track of us it is well
they're probably having the time of
their lives because humans are fun yeah
I mean what if we are the reality show
for aliens
I would watch us or we are aliens in a
VR we're in a simulation cuz they could
play the characters yeah oh I think all
right thank you all right the dumbest
things ever they're like God these guys
right right when their partners leave
they tend to touch this pole on their
pets really frequently fall asleep we
don't get the shows we're like one step
above monkeys because monkeys will do it
in front of you hmm and some humans will
do it like all of humans were straights
sure feel like [ __ ] at each other they
also have comedy yeah
they crack when they crack the [ __ ] up
is so dope do they fall and in their
[ __ ] they start rolling backwards we
started a religion recently monkeys have
found religion oh I heard they're moving
into the Stone Age now - they're like
using like tools they're evolving anyway
that's not this article all right this
one is a man who regularly regularly
wears homemade religious armor dies
after taking it off orgy
so I mean it sucks that he died he got
into a [ __ ] argument with his wife
and this is what she said to him you're
such a [ __ ] loser that's not gonna do
[ __ ] take that [ __ ] off and he finally
takes it off and he gets stabbed by
spear a spear yeah what is a religious
arm okay okay what are those things are
they like talismans um they're amulets I
mean that's from what religion buddhist
yeah positi die it's in its china press
let's see okay it was his wife that
yelled at him for sure if this was he
was a man from Thailand what if the
spirits were telling him to do that and
then he listened to his wife then and he
took it off in and he died the moment he
thinks about the spirits possessed his
why I have to be like take it off yeah
but the other good spirits were like you
need to do this you're gonna die yeah so
he tried to warn them he took it off one
day cuz he was just going down the
street to grab something I was at a
store and well it wasn't really a store
is like the marketplace and a small
truck just freakin railed into him Oh
Hilton it's silly chances I know and
they like ruin the store like the shop
owner was like my store but like that
guy super mario over the store with the
same day
that's sad it's really sad in the same
day I rot it was that like within an
hour he just took off because usually he
leaves with his armor and a helmet on
every day it's like his the helmets made
out of burial its - it was feeling extra
confident he went out with it without
his armor and helmet for as just to
drive out to a close by retailer this um
articles kind of written in broken
English but it appeared like any day for
anybody else but it was the most tragic
day of his life
because he took off his amulets and then
all of a sudden was hit by a small truck
the collision Rim hidden into the shop
and then he died on the spot
Wow at least she died fast yeah
hopefully hopefully there was a big
sword in front of the truck so just say
it prompted the shops items might fall
into disarray and the roof debris rise
so that means he got a [ __ ] hit into
the store right and then he survived
that he was like thank God and then the
roof and then he survived the roof big
and then when he finally came out the
rubble another truck you know in time
Mario said oh no looky what happy all
the rod knives gone and the truck driver
is being tried in court for inflicting
demise by negligence Tim I thought the
wife is she like a accomplice oh there's
no way
that's what they would just say I bet
that's what happened through look like a
1970s Japanese superhero like the you
know like the [ __ ] the Beatle man you
know like one of those guys that
Lawrence coming up yeah you guys have
superstitions my dad was a rosary
because we have a friend that when he
leaves a place he has to triple check
the locks every time triple check [ __ ]
is ev0 it has a check check check check
check check
oh no that's that's his OCD super
superstition is like don't whistle at
night because ghosts will come or some
[ __ ] like well there's sound like
there's a lot in Mexican culture one of
them is like you don't want to put like
females at least they don't want to put
their purse on the ground or else you're
gonna like lose money so that would like
you bet for me now because stuff on a
chair on a couch huh well I think it's
been embedded in my head so much that I
purposely go [ __ ] that so I try to put
it on the floor anything feels weird I
always put on the floor cuz that's
luggage and then I was trying to pull on
you put on for you not supposed to put
your purse on the floor oh I know I
always do that and people call me out
for it and I'm like I because I like
lose money
I don't yeah I didn't used to have a
purse and Steve made me buy a purse
because I kept losing my you still carry
just my debit cards and everything just
loose in my pocket it's a terrible idea
but I hate superstitions and just being
controlled that I like I have to fight
it so I'm like I'm put in a [ __ ] if I'm
throwing money and it was too dirty and
it's covered full of dust I have to I
just hate really controlled by some [ __ ]
that doesn't make sense it's an IV with
a Bloody Mary thing you know the Bloody
Mary
what started my insomnia when I was a
kid oh no I'll be like good in there I
did that [ __ ] in the mirror she didn't
come in the bathroom but she's gonna
come in when I'm [ __ ] sleep in that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah so up until I was like 28 I would
reach in 28
I would reach my hand in the bathroom to
smell the life
oh no I fight it like you I'll run to
the bathroom in the dark and I'm like I
don't care I have to be fifth grade
because how [ __ ] lazy is Bloody Mary
like she sees your army she goes not
into the full body well she doesn't see
me like night night yeah do you know
there's a law that like things don't
exist until you look at them where's
this written it's like this like I
proposed theory of a holographic
universe that things don't exist unless
you look unless you see them I agree
because there's times where I'm looking
for something and it's right in front of
my like face and then I'm looking a
looking at and because my mind is not
really thinking of looking for it I just
keep telling myself only that I miss it
and then I go slow the [ __ ] down and
then I look slowly and I'm like and you
made it create doesn't that mean it's
always been there
but your dumb ass overlooked it it
wasn't there till she saw it yeah
exactly
no it was that because Bart is in the
court is like that's right there yeah
well then then Bart made it happen cuz
he saw it yeah the dumbest theory on
earth what the tree falls and there's no
one there doesn't make a sound yeah
that's all the squirrels about well you
got the glasses on the top of your head
you know where to [ __ ] on my glasses and
you feel it first
dude I try to call my phone from my
phone that's another level you should
have never shared that story I do really
dumb things but I'm really academically
smart but people probably won't believe
me but you know sometimes some people
people are smart and then you know the
common sense has yeah [ __ ] all like
common sense dumb [ __ ] all the time
that's all good I threw away my keys in
the garbage can multiple times that make
sense yeah I'm like scatter banks I'm
thinking of a thousand things at the
same time and then I just like I'm sure
you don't have a TD maybe I might
come on over to the dark side do you
have it - I don't know there was a
psychologist that DM me on Instagram and
she wanted me to talk to her a DD
students and in she already spoke to me
as if I had it so bad
she's like clearly he knows that he has
it since you're a survivor I was like I
how do you cope with this in your daily
life cope with what exactly she's like
how did you you know overcome a lot of
them and I was like well you are hitting
all the things you know what I did look
at the list of traits of would and in
looking back as a kid I'm like oh yeah I
hit all those traits maybe I did live
with I don't know I never got formally
died at that time though everybody was
being formally diagnosed like any high
energy child they were given out which
is a child Ritalin and Adderall and all
that [ __ ] all day every day
what a presumptuous [ __ ] though that's
like somebody coming up you'd like to
you know exactly guys we gotta stick
together
[Laughter]
he's pissed out you know what's [ __ ]
mousses right like there's different you
know spectrum sometimes I pull and yell
at Steve in the morning like if I have
too much in my head I like I can't talk
to you I don't know you're saying too
much in my head and I get really mad
because like like there's like all these
different items that's just being a
woman girl I need to sort them I think
the biggest thing would be if somebody
is a hard time paying attention if
somebody's like engaged in conversation
with you okay cuz I feel like people
with ADHD tend to kind of straight Oh a
a trigger word then I start thinking of
a different things
creative yeah like I think about how
that could be a sketch and then I start
laughing about it and I see it playing
in front of me well I'm not a
multitasker so like I I kind of
understand that so like Muriel
understands that if you asked me one
thing I'm gonna try to solve your one
thing don't ask me another question in
between that because I'm gonna finish
this task first the other day she was
like hey can you help me out with this
email I was like cool oz are working on
shows so what about this I was like you
know I can't I can't get me to ask me
two questions from different fields like
one is a what's in the fridge and the
other ones like about car is surely
better at being specialists and women
are better at multitasking that is why I
don't engage in roadhead because men
can't multitask so very smart thing
it's different than a woman masturbating
over anyway either ways dangerous no no
I mean they're technically both
distracted right so you know idiots
right
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]